[Musik]
neue unfähig oder warum kriege ich so
was ich bin ein glückskind und ich bin
da wo man eben die dinge kriegt die man
braucht
[Musik]
hallo willkommen im meer als logistiker
und weltweit für die taxifahrt das ist
wohl aussehen wie etwa 2 es gibt hier
viel zu tun das ist mal was genau ist
die logistik und darum ist die so ein
rückgrat für das historische treiben das
container zentrum der österreichischen
produzieren also etwas sorgen alle im
bundesrat ist direktes notierten
verbände und truppen wir errichten und
reparieren das militärische
computer-netzwerk im bundesland
oberösterreich wir betreiben 20
werkstätten verschiedene werkstätten
einziehen groß prüfstände und im
durchschnitt 30 der länge 1 10
verschiedenen lehrberufe nicht nur
einjährigen ja werde ich weiter zum
provisorischen kfz-techniker ausbilden
ich beginne die ich dem
werkstättenleiter die wirklich zuerst
einmal umkehren damit du dann eine
grundüberholung beziehungsweise service
an dem waffensystem leopard 2
durchführen kannst bereit
hallo oma früher gleich den ersten
arbeitsschritt in angriff nehmen
kinder spielen danke
[Applaus]
[Musik]
robert ist möglich begrüßen wir machen
in dieser halle motor und getriebe grund
überholungen wochen dass das ganze
bundesministerin der band wert steht du
wirst du sie hast du hast durch das
komplett gegart ausgebaut worden
jetzt ist es bei uns was kann ich es
dass die quelle mit mir ein baum während
des 10
[Musik]
[Applaus]
viel elektronik das gerade so logistik
dazu so ist er sehr du bist ja endlich
klappte
wir sind zuständig für die zutritt sage
alarmanlagen netzwerk sowie telefoniert
was haben wir da die kamera bei motor
ist ausgefallen
das ist das beschädigte kabel und das
muss jetzt sozusagen neu
zusammengesetzten aus dass er diese
jetzt circa 13
wunderbar mit diesem charakter heimat
nie betreten und dann ist der wunderbar
abschnitten dann hier einbringen
so steckte zu der liste an gerät so
bildet die beiden glasfasern
das müsste eigentlich das bild bekommen
na bitte in ist glasfaser wir
beschlossen
demnach seien ganzjährig
sowohl halt bevor die etwas mit dem west
lassen wird hier etwas hat geben bevor
ich was mitgehen lassen
das hätte man damit du eine rechnung
hast du den heutigen tag im heeres
logistik zentrum willst tierischen wird
das über regen ist cool tag war ich
hoffe es erhält einen würdigen platz bei
dir zu hause habe das amt ausgeschieden
nein das ist vielen diemtigtaler scheint
große respekt dollars um 80 dankeschön
weitermachen sagte dass zum austrag
sagen herzlich willkommen gegen heeres
logistik zentrum in salzburg
zurückgekehrt in meiner militärische
heimat nämlich in schwarzenberg kaserne
aber da waren alle schwarz weiß logistik
der kirche für dazu was alles dazugehört
zuschauer sahen wir befinden uns hier
auf der zentralen material achse und
dreh und angelpunkt für unsere tägliche
versorgung führung in der uns anderen
regal anlagen befinden sich circa 36
tausend verschiedene artikel wir beim
herren einen diese versorgungsgüter und
wir stehen so die tägliche versorgung
der österreichischen armee im in und
ausland sichert und kann robert wir
haben einiges für die ich heute gibt es
braucht eine tatkräftige unterstützung
was vorher so was haben wir eins
gefunden
[Musik]
wir sind jetzt beim hochregallager hier
werden unsere großteile eingelagert das
mal anschauen hier natürlich nehmen
platz in unserem hochregale pharma in
den eingang hinein auf 19 meter hinauf
und den gang entlang
jetzt die am gameplay lagerhaltung
bietet die anlage und natur das ist ja
ganz einfach ja wohl
enter
[Musik]
na dann befehl ist befehl
hallo robert oeser das ist ziemlich
expressiver platz denn das gibt es nur
hier
es ist dieses thema steht eine abteilung
für das geschützte fahrzeuge cruiser
davos wieder hinter uns stehen haben das
bleibt natürlich ein bisserl einer
gewissen reparatur ich bin ein einfacher
typ gibt es mal ein facharbeiter das ist
hat jeder darf einfache tätigkeit der
trafo in kauf dass es im anschluss mit
meinem mitarbeiter die motorhaube
montieren ich bin bereit darunter ein
[Musik]
so hey hey hier vorstellen das ist jetzt
chefin ja quasi ich habe dann haben wir
schon mal ein ganz kleiner teil
hier werden auch lehrlinge ausgebildet
und du bist die lehrlingsausbildung
bereiche alle vier räder werkstatt zum
fall haben wir eben drei lehrlinge mhz
salzburg da haben wir jetzt eigentlich
sind verschiedene richtungen halt wie
eben kfz tischlerei schlosserei ekd und
lobbyisten du selber hast hier auch
bekommen
ich habe derzeit macht lehre mit matura
in einer natürlicherweise übernommen
waren und ihre chefin dann zeigen was
sie so macht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
logistik ist das was wo man um 16 uhr
dann einfach mal aus veranlasst nein das
ist ein job der einen trend reserven
fesselt die ganze zeit braucht
irgendjemand irgendwo etwas und ganz
dass alles da sein
wie funktioniert es in dem alle immer
arbeiten zum beispiel auch hier mitten
in der nacht wo container verladen
werden
wie das genau funktioniert ich habe
keine ahnung
und jetzt das kind nicht einmal
geschafft mein zimmer zusammen zu räumen
für mich war das wirklich faszinierend
wie das alles ineinandergreift damit
jede kleinste schraube oder der größte
partner dort eintreffen wo sie sein
müssen und zwar termingerecht und das
noch dazu im bestzustand wie auf der
einen seite repariert wird auf der
anderen seite sortiert wird und das
ganze alles auch noch richtig gelagert
wird damit jeder zu jedem zeitpunkt
zugriff auf alles hat das ist für mich
wahrscheinlich ewig ein spanisches dorf
aber für die das können ist das
österreichische bundesheer und das ist
die logistik
[Musik]